hi everyone my name is inis lichter and
i'm a professor at the institute of
biochemistry at the leicester university
medical faculty
i have been working on adhesion type g
protein called receptors for almost all
of my scientific career and i am excited
that a lot of the things and the
knowledges that we acquired in the past
10 years is now coming to such a nice
and round story that
i want to present you today and i really
think that um the information that we
gathered already is already aiming at an
angle to start thinking about
therapeutic implications
and this is where i want to hopefully
get you
and follow me through this story and
maybe in the end you'll agree this is
going to be a very interesting target
for future therapeutic interventions
so today we'll be talking about giants
we're not talking small we're talking
really big molecules
and
these big molecules can be somehow
compared to what is sequoia trees
compared to other normal trees because
adhesion gccrs
are very large they can become up to
four they can be up to 6500 amino acids
while an average reduction like gbcr is
approximately uh 400 amino acids so you
see there's uh quite a distinction in
that adhesion tbcrs are very old so in
that they don't really differ much from
from other g protein coupled receptors
we have 33 members in the human genome
but we already know that there's more
than 100 different flight variants and
that's easy to follow thinking that the
locus of the tgg are so big you can have
multiple um
like up to a 30 40 exons that can be
shuffled around and interestingly these
slice variants are tissue specific and
they can really differ in their
functions so if we look at it we're
actually dealing with a lot more than
those 33 acknowledged at hgbcrs
like other cheaper encounter receptors
also members of this
class govern essential physiological
functions
which renders some highly interesting
drug targets yes the majority of them
are still considered to be often
even though we've made quite a bit of
progress they are so far not a single
small molecule or any other derived
agonist available it can specifically be
used to target and teach gdpr
when we look at them we find very easily
the explanation for the normal size of
these receptors it all lies in the very
complex interpreters as you can see in
the picture
this enterprise contains
these blue adhesive domains they're
represented there above the
barrel like shape
in gray yellow and orange which is all
part of a highly conserved gpcr
autoproteolysis inducing
this gain domain is doing exactly
what the name says it's inducing an
autoprolitic cleavage event as the
receptor matures in the end systematic
particular
and that means that the receptor is
already shuffled as a functional
heterodimer to the cell membrane
that clean instrument also marks the
start of an encrypted tethered agonist
that we refer to as the shuffle sequence
and that stafford sequence is
also highly conserved amongst among a
lot of adhd gpcrs
as i already mentioned we have these
functional domains in the n-terminus and
they receive signals from the cellular
environment so it has been shown that
extracellular matrix molecules including
collagen laminates or contracting
sulfates can bind to the receptor the
same as cell surface molecules among
them ce 55 immigrants or notch
the knowledge that we have gathered in
the past years is that there is
basically three
different ways of how achieving gps
errors can be activated the first one is
a very classical one particularly in
public receptors you can use small
molecular agonists or even antagonists
or peptides that are derived from the
type of diagonal sequence and they all
bind into the putative because it hasn't
defined it
binding poppet
often teaching gpcr which should be
localized somewhere in the seven
transmembrane domain that we know from
truncation mutants
on the other hand side the interaction
with the extracellular matrix molecules
can also lead to receptor activation
not just finding even though that has
not been shown sufficiently for all
adhesion gprs with known interaction
partners
but
we are getting more more information
that this might actually be happening
here
and then
third option is we can apply mechanical
forces adhesion gps or also mechanical
sensors
so the first part of my talk
will focus on
the activation that we have seen on the
adhesion gptr by
stuffing like peptides and small
molecules
and i will guide you through this based
on one exemplary receptor and that is
the adhesion gpcr gp126
that receptor has been our pet receptor
basically everything that that my group
does and that we learned
is based on the findings of this
specific adhesion gpcr and you see here
in the figure that it has the classic
features of an adhesion gptr there's the
gain domain as functional adhesive
domains you have a cup and the pendrives
in the main and apart from that there's
the seven transmembrane domain
that receptor
became very interesting to us because it
was published
quite a few years back by kelly monk who
was at that point the post doc in talbot
lab and she had a project where she
could show the mutation of tbr126
induces a myelination death deficit
phenotyping zebrafish
so to explain to you you see here in
those pictures on the right
this is a myelin basic protein staining
of a superficial larvae
and in the box below the bigger picture
you see an enlargement of the peripheral
nervous system and you see a nice thing
for the wild type while on the picture
below you see the st63 mutants and there
is a quite a lack of myositation
the interesting part about this mutation
is is that it's not a complete knockout
it's a so-called hypomorph because the
mutation is located in the first
extracellular loop
and it results in a decreased expression
of the receptor so there's still some
receptor left that could in theory be
activated but it's not enough to help
establishing a fully healthy myelination
phenotype
so the next thing we did
or that kelly does is basically looking
at mine the phenotype is actually
conserved among different species so you
can find the same
thing in mice
so what you see in the upper picture
is a normal
psychiatric nerve in mice while below is
the knockout animal and what you can see
with the black arrows is that in the
knockout animals this psychiatric nerve
is much paler and thinner and these mice
have a very terrible motor deficit as
well
so knowing that there is uh somehow a
myelination deficit in these animals and
based on another aspect that was
published by kelly that you can rescue
that phenotype with zebrafish applying
forcefully it was quite likely that
gpr126 actually induces cyclic amp
levels in the cell through g is public
and that is quite interesting because it
has been known for many years that
different levels of cyclic gmp govern
the proliferation and the
differentiation process of
swan cells so as long as the schwann
cell differentiating it needs low levels
of cyclic amp
while the switch from proliferation to
differentiation
is induced by some burst of cyclic ap
and so we cloned that receptor
overexpressed it in constant cells and
found that actually already basal
activity is high enough to detect an
increase of cyclic amp level and that
level is
quite markedly reduced when we knock out
cheaper 126 with specific irony well you
have
a rebound of these levels when you just
use control as irony situations
but then again it's nice to know that
there's some psychic amp signaling and
this was actually the first time that
our
real functional interaction
um in this g-protein-mediated pathway
was shown for the receptor but then
again what we really want is to be able
to activate the receptor
and for that um we did some meditational
mutational experiments and found that
there's quite likely
also a tested argument sequence
encrypted there and to prove that and to
be able to use that as a toolbox
we had a synthetic peptide library uh
design which was based on the encrypted
tested active sequence in the receptor
itself and you can see the first amino
acid is always the threatmen that is the
first amino acid after the cleavage site
and then the tested actin sequence is
differing um from all the way up to the
transparent transmembrane one and then
subsequently shortened
and these peptides were applied
to
a receptor truncation mutant that does
not harbor the test effect of the
sequence anymore as you can see in the
upper panel with no peptide there's no
activation of basal activity here and
you can you can recover that activity by
applying a peptide and the most
efficient one we found was a peptide
with a length of 16 amino acids
again if you
if you shorten or elongate that p16
peptide then you lose the activity so
here we have quite a good idea of what
the what the best peptidic agonist
derived from the shuffle sequence could
be
so as nice as it is as it is to have
something like that for in vitro
settings it's much more important if you
can actually use it in an amiibo
environment
so here we got into conflict with kelly
we had our own lab by then
and they tested that same hypomorph
mutant that i already introduced to you
with the peptides
in the upper panel you can see that
applying being this all or the p16
peptide does not really change much in
the myelination of wild type zebra fish
well when you do the same thing with the
st63 mutant all of a sudden there's a
marked increase in violation and if you
want to take a closer look in the paper
off this has been quantified
and
it's indeed significantly rescued
so
that was the story to the test of
darkness peptides again these peptides
do have a bit of a problem because
they're highly hydrophobic so um they're
hard to dissolve
and they're also not really specific for
the receptor as the binding pocket is
quite well conserved so you have cross
activity between different adhdrs
so there was of course quite an interest
to find small molecule compounds that
could somehow modulate the receptor
activity
and in this case um this study that i'm
showing you here was initiated by
kelly's lab they used their hypomorph
zebrafish readout
to test hundreds of compounds
for a rescue of that phenotype and among
some of the compounds that did increase
myelination was apomorphin
and they asked us if we can reproduce
the findings that apomorphin likely
activates gp126
and that is the cause for writing that
phenotype we can show that in an over
expression specific system
and
by doing that incubating gta 126 wi-fi
cells with equal morph and show the
concentration
of dependent increase of cyclic amp
levels while you could not see this for
anti-vector transact itself
on the other hand side another opioid
derivative codeine does not give us this
type of specific activation but then
again
talking about specific is a little bit
difficult here as uh april morphine is
obviously a dopaminergic agonist as well
so it's not an ideal candidate either
but out of that whole
study that we did all of those other
compounds that did rescue the phenotype
none really show the receptor specific
activation in our essays
so now we come to the next part how can
extracellular matrix molecules induce
activation so as i already said they are
not just interacting they can actually
lead to signal production in the cell
and often enough
when we talk about ecm molecule
activation
we also have to talk about mechanical
force activation because somehow that
mechanical or that ecm molecule needs to
be
introduced to act as a signal and the
force on the other hand side needs to be
translated to the receptor so it seems
obvious that these two things should go
hand in hand
so here for example keeper 126 the first
ligand that had been published
was done in that helmet lab and they
could show that collagen 4 interacts
with the cop and centric same domains of
gp126 and that this interaction leads to
an increase in cyclic amp level when
cells are transfected
with cheater 126. this is dependent on
an existing entrance
in a parallel study
shantial
in a collaboration with kelly had
identified lemon in 2011 to be a binding
partner of gpo 126 and they again asked
us if we could do some pharmacology
testing
um with this compound and interestingly
enough we could show that
concentration dependent um
activities of 2026 was actually reduced
so it looked like it was an inhibitor of
the receptor so what you would expect
from an inhibitor of g 126 in the
myelination phenotype would be
a worsening of the
so what they did
they overexpressed in kelly's lab
lemonade 211
in super fish larvae what you see here
is basically just a different way of
looking at myelination in green you find
pseudo-colored neurons
that have been properly myelinated
uh which you can see in the wild type
it's nicely happening the watertight
also overexpressing laminate 211 she was
pretty much the same picture
the same mutant sc63
um now it shows that myelination deficit
so you can see there's either two large
or very small neurons
being myelinated and it's a lot less
than in the wild type
and then when you overexpress lemon in 2
11
you get a rescue of that phenotype and
that's quite puzzling because that
rescue of that phenotype was dependent
on cyclic emp increase
while we could show that 11 into 11
decreases like a p level
and to kind of try and make sense of
this this controversy
we
have to go and take a look what is
actually happening with these molecules
what do they do in people right nature
can often provide you with answers that
you cannot come up yourself
and when you take a look back again in
the textbook you can see that before the
swan cell can start wrapping it's
myelinating it needs to start forming a
b cell lamina around the neuron and the
first thing serbia created is actually
laminin 2011 and it's secreted as a
monomeric protein
that then
binds and sits
on the neuron and later on starts
polymerizing and that polymerizing event
leads to some of
this like basic structural
of formation changes
and in the end what results is a leaky
basin membrane and at least the basal
membrane is then tightened
by collagen four collagen four comes and
sits them on the polymerized lemon in
2011 molecules
so we were thinking okay
so if you use collagen four in the in
vitro setting that pretty much
fits the same thing as it does in nature
but with lemon into 11 something else is
happening
and that something else might as well be
somewhat of a force something needs to
move mimic this because
we couldn't induce the polymerization in
our essay
so instead
we applied a mechanical force
based on vibration and here you see this
is again the basic setup anti-vector
and the last hair transfected gbo 126 we
chose lemon concentration which showed a
slight decrease inside the gamep um
production on wildforgible 126. and when
we then added the vibration
you could see that gp126 on its own is
already activated by the vibration but
when you then start combining 11 into 11
with vibration the change in activity is
even higher
so
again that is nice to know
but i think we can all agree that a
vibration is not really what's happening
there when we're looking at uh
schwarzer-mediated myelination
so we always
wanted to know when we were actually
asked what are the forces that are
really acting on the receptor what's
going on there
and to investigate that we set up an
atomic force microscopy experiment where
you see here in gray is the cantilever
and the candy liver can be
conjugated with different molecules
and these molecules then interact with
the receptor being transfected into the
cell the cell is also co-transfected
with a cyclic amp biocenter pink
flamingo
that allows you to detect cyclic dnp
production by an increase in
luminescence
so
we applied that approach
in the first part using collagen four we
coded a candy lever with collagen four
which should interact with the copper
synthetics and domains of gb126
and the first thing is
we push
onto the cells
and
pushing on anti-vector transfected cells
does not give you a result pushing on a
cleavage deficient gp126 does not give
you a result but pushing on the wild
type
with one nano newton force all of a
sudden gives you a significant increase
inside the kp production
so if you do more it's not going to make
it any better
um
doing less gives you a little bit of
psychic amp but not decisively
on the other hand side when we start
pulling
on the receptors we get nothing
so if you look at
the vitro setting i already told you we
can imagine that when we apply collagen
four onto cells being transfected with
gpa 126 it's sitting on the receptor
and gravity will pull it down so in that
way collagen 4 will sit and push on the
receptor
on the other hand side we can also think
that this makes sense
when we remember that collagen 4 is also
going to sit on top of that leading
basal membrane and that it could also
push onto chica 126.
so on the other hand side
when we use lemon in 211
and we push
we get nothing
still
no no ideas in in no way no psychic
gamep production but when we start
pulling with increasing pulling force we
already start seeing some activation
with 0.5 nanonewton but we really get a
significant increase in the second
messenger production when we pull with
0.75
nano newton
and that also makes sense when we think
that looking just a laminate on its own
sitting on the cell
basically keeps cycling p levels
at low keeping the receptor inactive i
guess if you just have enough at some
point you decrease activity
while when we apply vibration to
the cells being in the media that media
being vibrated will actually start
moving and that kind of moving can be
translated into a shear force meaning
that the lemon inbound to the receptor
could be moved away and never starts
pulling on the receptor
and that could be the signal that we see
when we apply vibrational forces and
that increases likelihood levels
and
that also explains or makes sense in in
light of the physiological settings
so
what we came up with in the end is that
we believe that the enteringness is an
allosteric module that basically
incorporates a lot of different signals
that come from the outside
so
we actually think that this is happening
to more than just cheaper 126. this
could be more generalized model for
adhesion gpcrs as we do know that
several of them have different ligands
and each ligand
then conveys a temporal
spatial force
specific intracellular signal
which means
when we consider therapeutic targeting
of vacation gpcrs
we should not just look at the seven
transmembrane and defining pockets or
maybe allosteric binding parts there
we should always think of the
interpreters itself
and if you consider that antibodies can
be created to specifically target
such a huge epitome i think we have a
lot of ideas on how to proceed next
so with that
i
want to conclude my presentation
i want to thank the people that really
did the main chunks of this work
first of all um of course the group uh
situated at the leicester university
at the
institute of biochemistry
and there is who did
all of these atomic force microscopy
experiments under the supervision of
camilla china and
we foreign thousand shirley back who
have been supportive of a lot of these
projects helping with ideas playing
around with explanations for many years
and then there's
kai and carol who both are just
indispensable for anything we do in this
lab
and then of course as i mentioned
several times kelly monk has been a very
close collaboration partner and a friend
over all these years and the same goes
for shen
who is also now at the university of
california in san francisco
and of course i want to thank
all the third party funding options that
we uh we had it's really great that we
can
pursue all these experiments and then
finally i want to thank you
for your time and your interest and
if you have further questions don't
hesitate to contact me
thank you